alright guys bangbang the legends here
Peter what's up man what's up alright
for the like two people who are
listening to this you don't know who you
are what's your background let's see I'm
down here in LA living in the dream by
the beach I run a small fund in LA
called science it's a seventy-five
million dollar early stage seed fund
attached to a startup studio kind of one
the first to do startup studios
basically means we helped start the
company's build them at b0 usually for
12 18 months
alongside the founders figure out kind
of what we're doing why we're doing it
fine product market fit we've been doing
that for about eight years in about the
last three years we've had a fun now
attach it all consumer internet products
and companies everything from things
you've maybe heard of Dollar Shave Club
was one of the first big breakouts dog
vacay which became Rover liquid death
and many other companies many fail some
succeeded and some are on its way you're
being incredibly humble because you guys
have probably one of if not the most
successful startups to do right so a lot
of accelerators kind of all these other
things that fund and help but the idea
of actually being there from day one and
helping create these companies is a
little bit different model you need some
different things you look for maybe talk
a little bit about as you guys have been
successful over the years like what does
the ideal team idea how it comes
together like what does that look like
through the pattern recognition that you
guys have developed we're pretty
thesis-driven so we have kind of like
find these markets that we really want
to focus over so right now brands which
we've always kind of done particularly
well looking at you know what's next on
your mobile phone like what else do you
need entertain that other been looking
at Instagram and snapchat and then the
other is you know what is the behavior
of post
right what is the how are we gonna
behave what kind of products and
services are we gonna use from there
it's just finding the idea that
resonates for me particularly it's kind
of like music right so one of things is
I love to dance first little dance
floors like part of my bio and just like
music I'm sure all music is great music
right for two different people but some
things make you dance and some things
make you home some things make you like
look at the artist play it over and over
add it to your playlist startups are
like that for me I'm sure there's lots
of great companies and startups but when
I see the startup that resonates with me
with the founder and I found her you
know particularly for us they want help
they want our opinion they want to kind
of learn they want to grow with us
that's what I'm looking for so it's a
look I'm I'm an all-in type of person
like you get to know me when I'm not
when I'm in I'm a hundred and ten
percent all in which means I kind of
want to feel like I'm a part of it and
so if I'm not offensively just loving it
I'm just gonna pass not to say it's an
indictment on you or the startup or the
idea it's just I just don't see myself
waking up and thinking about it 24 hours
a day so it's a little convoluted but
for me it's a little bit more gut in
instinct of course the founder is
everything so from the outside looking
in and I've seen a number of deals and
you guys have done over time each of
them has kind of some differences but
there is the commonality of there's
almost this like cult-like following
behind some of the brands and so liquid
death and Dollar Shave Club are probably
two great examples of that maybe talk a
little bit about the Dollar Shave Club
story and kind of how do you take a
business which at the outset for most
people the first time they heard about
it was this wild video that the CEO is
featured in - all of a sudden within a
number of years it's a billion dollar
exit like how does that happen and
what's going on behind the scenes that
you guys are doing to help kind of
really help that team become not
successful you know that is always gonna
be the vision and the genius of Michael
Tiemann
right he is when I met him the first
time
I just thought to myself this is one of
the most creative persons I've ever met
he's he's Branson thirty years ago right
just brand creative like if you think
about what Brandt says being able to
take the Virgin brand and create
multiple things each and every time I'm
in just understand culture that was a
big part of it the other was that of
course that
razorblades everyone loves to heat it so
there are certain things in the world
people love to heat right so I like the
other example uber works because
everyone loved to hate taxis like you
could just walk up to somebody like
taxis what a pay me ask like don't you
hate it yes razor blades at the time
Gillette it's like you had to shave you
had to buy their $30 razor blades and
you could walk up to anybody said can
you believe they're ripping us off don't
you kind of hate it yes so there's that
part of it then it's how you approach it
and Mark it with that and use that
virality it was funny it was the first
kind of opening when YouTube started
taking off in facebook so this is gosh
it's almost eight years ago eight and a
half at the time we were one of the
first people ever to use YouTube as a
lead generation run a viral video to an
advertisement and didn't that was the
first using Facebook in the commenting
session and using the creative as an ad
unit and using the comment section and
creating virality through that so it was
a combination of timing right based on
marketing tactics that you can have
reach with people and understanding that
word-of-mouth it's like this thing that
we've been hurt you know ever since
college like you would hear about word
of mouth but eight years ago it was the
first time when you knew that a hundred
people could be hurt
5,000 to 10,000 10 million people all
through Facebook all through YouTube so
that was a big part of it so you go from
that which is many people will say
that's great Peter but that kind of
window of time has passed right and
those have become commoditized so now
something like liquid death which has a
lot of the same kind of features if you
will
the first time I saw it you literally
were taking pictures posting it all over
the Internet and I said what is he doing
and at first it was a good joke at first
and then I think that's South by
Southwest maybe you were handing out
cans right and a couple other
conferences like oh wait this is like a
real thing and the second that you put
the can in your hand and realize like
there's magic here right I don't know
what it is whatever we ended up putting
a very small check in alongside you guys
kind of taking this really well
sounds like was an idea and a brand and
now scaling it out to what it's become
so like how do you recreate the magic of
Dollar Shave Club with a different
product different brand is there a
formula to it or is it just kind of
again moment in time different tactics
same strategy different kind of
platforms so Facebook's programmatic at
this point now we're talking Instagram
snapchat but real Instagram so think
about visual that for me when I heard
about it it was the moment when we had
just started banning plastic straws
right so there's always to me there's
this meta thing culturally that's
happening and as investors we're
supposed to kind of not tell the future
but like for me this early hey what's
what's gonna be culturally relevant
twelve eighteen months from now right in
12 to 18 months so it's been liquid
that's been about to do so about 14
months in or so when we launched but I
saw it a year and a half ago at that
time we just banned plastic straws and I
thought huh plastic straws the social
spread of how we're becoming a little
bit more aware of the environment how
the whale is you know washing ashore
with 90 pounds of plastic in its belly
right and people are excited to talk
about plastic plastic plastic I thought
well maybe plastic water bottles like
that I've always thought it's kind of
gross like that's you and then you look
at the you look at the data it's
unbelievable how much plastic box is
happening then there was this Atlantic
article about two years ago that said
China stopped buying our trash so wait a
minute so if China's not buying our
trash or recycle anymore
we just ban plastic straw
there I thought there would be this
movement honestly about now it happened
a lot earlier than I expected
we're passing bottles are going to be
kind of the cigarette cigarette but of
our generation you see somebody smoking
a cigarette you're like really it's not
as culturally okay these days and then I
don't really I don't drink I'm actually
allergic to alcohol and for a very long
time I would always like holding this
feels just natural and then lastly it's
content if we've noticed during this
pandemic are you opening up Instagram as
often it's kind of boring it turns out
like nobody's doing anything content
people want something I need to talk
about holding a candle to death in
person someone's gonna walk up to you
and say hey what's that I will guarantee
it hundred times
someone's gonna do it and ultimately
people go to bar as people go to parties
to talk to other people but turns out
not everyone's like you or me who's an
extrovert most people are an introvert
and to give somebody something to talk
about that is universal kind of like oh
that's cool yeah and don't you hate
plastic water bottles yes again that
goes back to the universally we all love
to hate plastic water bottles right and
in a lot of cases drinking alcohol is a
peer pressure environment and this kind
of eases that environment and gives you
something to talk so it's a lot of
conversation and it's going back to what
you're saying you're using the same
tactics give something for somebody to
talk about Dollar Shave Club funny viral
video like I can't believe it's third
that they charge thirty bucks this is
six bucks what a deal
disruption was mailing I mean honestly
mailing something to your house on a
subscription eight and a half years ago
this didn't exist we were the first
company I asked those Collison brothers
to create a recurring payment system on
strike that didn't exist right we like
it was kind of this is before Shopify
this is before everything that it makes
it so easy to click and subscribe to
things now for liquid death it's just
content content content now you're
saying well we have almost a hundred
thousand Instagram fans what
to content 25 people gone tattoos
someone just got married with it like we
made a a heavy metal album with it it's
content and people just want to talk
about it so it's all about marketing
ultimately part of what cracks me up too
specifically around liquid death is the
haters yes marketed as well right
they're literally like I remember when
the articles came out about the fund
raise like people are like this is the
dumbest thing ever right and you're like
I appreciate you sharing that article
like thank you you just drove sales well
we talked about this it emboldened
everybody else so look you see it in
politics right and you see them product
which is people there's gonna be a 10%
of public who hate everything they see
and just for whatever reason this offend
is a lot of people I don't know why but
it just offended people and those people
called everybody else who liked it I
thought it was cool and idiots dumb
whatever name-calling you can possibly
hurl edits that made everybody else say
you know what I'm not done I'm not don't
consume I like screw you I'm all in and
this goes to if you look at politics
today when you a one end you just call
blatantly anybody who disagrees with you
and idiots it turns out it emboldens and
it takes all the people who are moderate
to pick a side and generally when you're
in the middle and you're like really no
opinion you go with the pristine ecology
media or do you go with the side that
you're kind of arty on typically it's on
this side so yeah some of our best
performing ads right now on liquid death
are he ads so the the the heavy metal
album was called the greatest hates yeah
that's what cracks me up the right is
like actually the brand has embraced the
haters and shares like here here's the
best hateful comments and which makes
people just laugh right and you actually
see like Jeff Bezos right now is
embracing this as what he's taking
customer emails who are backlash against
him supporting black lives matter and
he's posting them on Instagram and being
like you're a customer on
you lose right and people almost kind of
gravitate towards that oh because your
because fans of it who can identify just
like you you've made lifelong fans right
and look there's the big dear God and
we'll compare the two right one is doing
the right thing and saying look I have
an opinion and if you don't share with
me that's a lot here's this is when I
think about marketing haters will always
hate you can't convince them otherwise
but to me when you start hurling insults
that's use those because at the end of
the day I I'm sure you I don't know I
love you I'm sure many people but I'm
sure you have haters and I've haters it
is what it is like that ah I don't live
my life to seek approvals from everybody
else if you did that that's a sad life
right like do good things celebrate your
wins and ignore the haters that's what
they say I I can back up the fact that
you say that you are the first on the
dance floor is actually a fact I have
literally been with Peter when he has
been like hey nobody's on the dance
floor I will be the first and within 20
minutes there's a dance party every
single time I you know what it's funny I
think about why I do that I like
bringing joy like it's it's there's
something about dancing where most
people who stand around dance for like
be one like they would dance but they're
a little bit self-conscious and for me
and like if you just let go and just let
yourself have fun you'll notice
everybody else will just join you and
there's no more judgement when
everybody's doing right well soon as
everybody's doing something no judgement
but one person doesn't all of a sudden
it's like well should I should i and I
think dancing is one of those liberating
moments where you kind of let go what
you think about work disappears out of
your mind
there's a little bit freedom there's
this endorphin hit of just joy and
happiness like you'll never see a dance
for going off where there's sadness like
it was just
and so to me it's a challenge to walk
into a wedding a party of businessman
and just get the dance form if it's for
me it's a challenge because it's
marketing
so what am i doing I'm walking really
one by one trying to sell people to do
something in it to me that's just like
it helps me kind of tune the senses
around like having convinced people to
do something that's slightly other
comfort range but I know they want to do
it and as soon as they do it they're
gonna enjoy themselves
that's like to me it's a psychological
experiment my favorite thing that
anyone's ever said to me about you is
eyes either south South by Southwest for
Puerto Rico somebody came up to me and
they said man Peters really drunk and
they didn't know right they just they
were just like oh this guy's like
hammered I was like no no Pierre doesn't
drink like that's him 24/7
like he's just a happy dude right and
he's gonna get the dance party started
and I almost looked at it as like it was
such a compliment right they didn't
realize that but it was like a thing
where oh somebody who would have to get
drunk to kind of let down their
inhibitions in order to have that much
enjoyment and I was like no like he
makes a conscious choice to do that he
does it every single party is I just
remember kind of laughing to myself like
yeah he got another person like he just
you just converted somebody to the army
yeah if I could drink like you know
basically a little bit I can taste it I
don't swallow up it's about this much of
anything I'm basically currently I don't
and I get it right like to let down all
your guards and just go all-in on
something it's like it's great feeling
so I just naturally one of the the
latest companies that you guys have done
that I think a lot of people are paying
attention to is a play vs and maybe talk
a little bit about kind of how that came
together with d'Alene and how you guys
have built it so quickly I think I think
a lot of people are sitting there saying
like great idea d'Alene is obviously
speaks for himself in terms of how he's
been as an entrepreneur but like this
thing has gotten so big so quickly and
like how that's come together yeah look
I mean I have like goosebumps when I
talk about no lame so and I think now
this week or the last couple weeks I've
been talked about
a lot you know he's one of those
founders I met him at South by right
this goes back to there's an Arctic I
did USA Today this week around like
networking and what I'm missing so this
is cool we hit the cap we caught up a
little bit before the zoom call but it's
not the same as just serendipity
running into people meeting people I'm
one of those people I go to every
conference I'm looking to meet people
and a couple years back at South by
Southwest
during there's a side event called
culture house that's put on by just
amazing black entrepreneurs and
investors and it's really coming to this
side of emphasis look sapphires you know
mostly whites a lot and years ago they
said let's put together this event and
culture house and so they were serving
brisket which is my favorite from
Franklin's by the way and my favorite
barbecue in the world you gotta go if
you have not been in Franklin's like
just do it and I meant d'Alene on the
dance floor and it was a it was a house
and they were serving barbecue
they were playing hip hop which I love
there was no dance for per se I was just
really just the only person dancing and
Suzie rube from cross culture cross
culture fund in LA with Troy Carter
introduced me delay named Elaine was a
you know he grew up in Atlanta he's a
bot kidding Atlanta father's murder
before he's born group was just in the
projects and he was 24 at the time but
just had this like hustle just like this
passion and like sharpness to him that
I'll never forget and we just started
talking about eSports and we you know
it's one of the thesis is for science as
a fund and investment is is what's more
entertaining than your phone and
Instagram what's actually video games
and I thought eSports is going to take
off we just didn't know what what's
gonna be and you know I met delay on the
dancefloor as the story goes and
convinced him over the next like two
months to move out to LA and let's go
figure what we should build so he on a
Friday dropped everything Monday moved
out to LA and for a couple months we
kind of figured out that you know what
are we gonna build and it ended up play
versus which is a platform for eSports
in all new US high school
and soon be colleges if you kind of
think about fantasy football
right which be interesting we had that
this year but fenneis footballs spread
across CBS Yahoo NFL comm ESPN profanity
sports
imagine if there's one service the
service all fantasy football that's what
play versus is and so the scale of that
the reason I think people are surprised
the speed is globally it's big us not so
much but you know one of the things in
my back of my head was thinking a little
bit ahead if I've been heist like high
school football like how's that it's
going to be a sport for another decade I
mean all the data is coming out the
concussions concussions concussions and
realities were also sue-happy nation and
at some point the liability will
probably outweigh the entertainment risk
and rightfully so eSports is gonna be a
sport in high schools in very quickly
within the first year we're rolling it
rolled out into 23 states where you can
play League of Legends
you could play video games essentially
that are esports globally in high school
get a letter win a state championship
and we raised almost 100 million dollars
in the first 18 months and to me look at
the time this is you know d'Alene Road
raised the most money
any black founder has ever raised for a
consumer internet company in that short
amount of time and this is you know
special to me like I was born in a
refugee camp right I grew up very poor
we grew up in a one-bedroom apartment
five kids seven of us and you know got
to the point in life both my pants were
social workers you know my mom handed
out welfare cheque for 25 years and so I
understand different levels of poverty
he grew up in the projects way tougher
neighborhood I grew very tough
neighborhood was his worse and so but I
grew up with the father he didn't that
to me is you know a lot of it is him he
is grown as an individual he is a CEO of
a company that is going to be most
likely the biggest investment and
biggest company that we've ever been a
part of for sure and so why did it grow
so fast he's an animal
he's just just lights out he will
impress anybody to market timing and
then it turns out in this pandemic when
schools are closed eSports video games
look at the stocks of every video game
company in the world right now it has
been up into the right and kind of going
into hopefully when we open schools
contact sports and things that where
you're near and close to people by not
so much eSports whatever you think about
it as an Asian I think about this what
if I tell if I told my parents hey mom
dad I got a scholarship to play chess in
college they would be so proud when you
think about eSports five-on-five it's
the strategy is unbelievable you are
thinking 5 10 20 steps ahead you have to
react instantaneously while
communicating with 4 other players on
your team it's actually next level
3-dimensional offense defense planning
strategically what do we do in life in
real life as jobs as career adults
strategy offense defense thinking as
many steps ahead whether you're a stock
trader whether you're an entrepreneur
whether you're a manager you are trying
to communicate with your peers you're
trying to grow your company you're
trying to preach strategy to me it's a
life skill so that's why it's so big
it's been amazing to watch and and I've
hung out in person with Delaine
everything you just said you're
underselling him right I mean he is the
real deal when I ask people for four
questions for you before we recorded the
number one question was how the hell
does Peter Pham raise so much money over
and over and over again for the
companies that he works with I think you
will be the first to say it really comes
down to the founders and their vision
and kind of what they're building
outside of that right so
so don't spend a lot of time on that
outside of that what makes a good
fundraise and a bad fundraise process
now that you can't do it so many times
have been so successful over the years
yeah numbers put it is that I've
probably done for the science portfolio
companies that I'm deeply deeply
involved with we've raised some like 700
the companies that have advised been
help friends raise been a part of
whether founder CEOs myself attack on
another PI billion so pipe somewhere in
the realm of about two billion dollars
and that's it's over a decade or so and
a lot of that is it turns out to me
that's numbers so in every realm no
matter what I'm talking to seventy we're
talking seventy eight a hundred people
so lots of news we're talk
so I'm somewhere in the seven thousand
no range like it knows or soft-nosed
quick knows and I'm going for the no I'm
trying to find the person where time and
space just align like I am looking for
that investment I am thinking about that
space I have the dollars to commit at
this point and it turns out there's the
system is pretty inefficient right you
just have to find the investor in the
right moment in the right frame of time
to get a yes in most cases the the most
important part of this is a story so
countless times is and I think my
superpower and the skills I could take
most ideas most pitches and just reframe
it and tell the store in a different way
that will be more compelling you have to
remember this investor I think I can
empathize which is they want to be part
of the journey like what's the hook to
make them feel like they're almost an
employee of the company like so where
they want to be excited to work for this
company that is the missing link the
other is what we called FOMO fear of
missing out what are the things where
it's obvious things are happening and
the momentum starting to happen and if I
don't get you to come on now you're
gonna miss out so it's framing the story
in the information
data in every stages event so I'll be
more practical super early I have an
idea an idea phase it is really kind of
I caught three phases of every pitch
what was the world before what how did
the world look before before iPhone
before for GE before Google Maps right
what exists now that allows what you're
doing what's changed essentially so if
you look at Dollar Shave Club well what
changed was like subscription I can mail
things right using media postal service
mail for like two dollars I could ship
everything goal all of the United States
for very inexpensively I can now create
and get things from Asia here much much
cheaper it's just easier right I can now
email marked it I can reach people on
Facebook I can reach me on YouTube
that's what's different right liquid
death what's different Instagram people
love sharing right people don't drink as
much plastic so like what in the world
around us has changed to allow you to
succeed and then what are you doing
differently than anybody so basically
what do you know that I don't know in
the world the rest of world is now
that's special so those are kind of
things like what did the world look like
before was world look like today what
are you doing to take advantage of that
and what's the world gonna look like
that's kind of like the story hierarchy
of any starting and I think if you just
thought through that a little bit and
get to the story quickly right I call it
cocktail conversations whoever you're
telling the story to whether or not the
decision-making are saying yes they have
to articulate that very quickly in a
sound bytes and remember and something
memorable to somebody it could be their
spouse it could be their colleague it
could be their partner it could be their
friend group because a lot of best
message most investors what's some
validation that they're not absolutely
insane for doing this right so a lot of
times the complicated story is too
complicated so what is different why now
you get them distilled down to a very
simple story and the last would be I
have this kind of plan once you start
growing
no matter the phase seed ABCD kept it
entirely don't talk about this publicly
okay for the 30 days for the 90 days
leading up to the fundraiser okay
can I go backwards for the next 30 days
as a founder and CEO you have 20 40 50
things you're trying to get accomplished
focus everything down to three things
that you know you can move the needle
and make what are those three things and
it's not always this top-line cumulative
revenue people think revenue it's not
revenue its percentages what's the
percentage of people renewing what's the
percentage of people coming back was a
conversion percentage what is the
average order in the cart going up my so
it's it's showing that things are
getting better right so as an investor I
want to know who ever gave you money
last time did you learn and did you grow
right were you efficient with that
capital because when I come in to invest
I kind of want to in a way I feel like
well the taking advantage of the last
investor like uh-huh they put in all the
hard money mine's the easy money right
so you have to prove that the money that
you took here's what I did here's what I
learned and this is it starting to
happen these things are really like we
we learned a lot we took the last
investor's money learned a ton and now
really staying around and I'm gonna take
your money increase that round and so no
matter what the startup you can have and
see that data so we have the company
pray calm so with all this lockdown
stuff churches are closed so pray calm
is subscription content similar to calm
and headspace but all based on religion
so what would investors care about well
not just new subscribers are they
listening to more content on each time
are they converting from download to
paid right arm or logging in or the
we're sharing it essentially velocity
velocity velocity you want to find
things where you're seeing an uptick in
a percentage update because top-line
revenue to me can be bought in any start
give me 10 million I'll buy ten million
dollars revenue that's very inefficient
what you want to show this for every
dollar that comes in I'm making things
faster and creating more efficiency in
the product the consumer love for it
since I'm you a consumer show me for a
fact that people love the dancing well
well 25 random people getting tattoos
people get married with the people I
think we saw half a million posts so far
I'm Instagram half a million about
Lupita well that tells you people truly
authentically love it right oh by the
way it's been in Whole Foods now for two
months it's now out out performing
vitaminwater its else you know we're
seeing acceleration every week week over
week more and more cases being sold so
then if I extrapolate that out as an
investor I say well okay so if I give
you money and there's more distribution
you're going to keep growing so it's all
about storytelling right but when you
look at the details of the data three
things that you're gonna focus on as a
founder and CEO and drive those things
and tell a story of why there's
correlation and causation that these
things are important for the future of
the company and it always comes down
cohorts if you don't know what the word
cohort is look it up right like the
customers that came in this week versus
comes to us next week where's the
customers like follow the journey of
those customers and show that the
customers that came in last month versus
this month everything's getting better
right there's logging in more often
their average order is higher like
Amazon take a big company Amazon Prime
or how many not just how many people are
Amazon Prime members but how many
renewed how are they spending more month
after month is it worth launching this
other thing well yes if they spend more
money right velocity velocity velocity
and sure as like most people the number
of boxes showing up
nor is increasing not decreasing in time
so well that means there being better
take that same example and take it to
your start there's always something
that's getting better if it's not it's
probably not working like if you can't
find anything in the data that shows
that there's some velocity happy even a
smaller maybe I don't care if you have a
hundred or thousand users something has
to be picking up steam if it's not time
to move on time to change ideas time to
change strategies bids because even in a
small sample you will find something
that's interesting if it's working and
so that's like the founder perspective
right of like what they can actually
drive you mission they're kind of 90
days pre actually going out for the
fundraise that's about 30 days of focus
what are you doing the other 60 days
well the next 30 days is the 30 days
focus 30 days of it actualizing right
it's it's working
things are going up into the right the
last 30 days is during the fundraiser
during the fundraiser it's continuing to
go up it's something if I talked to you
today on Monday when you check back in
on Thursday it got better when you check
in next week it's better you as an
investor start feeling like oh like the
trees it keeps going
I might miss out if I don't jump on
right I have the same called linear is
linear is flat if your data just goes
linear as an investor
why would I invest now when I can wait
when I know where it's gonna be next
month why would I invest now right if I
know where it's gonna be 3 months
meaning the example hey we're drawing
one customer a month or 1 million month
so it's June so in December you'll be 6
more million right
and then the year from now I'll be told
I'm not two years from now on time well
I can just wait pay more later but d
risk D risk by 95 9 plus percent of my
dollar risk right because risk as an
investor means
where are they gonna be next month six
months that's where all the risk is I
want to invest if I think that I don't
know like its it's just going up and
maybe in six months it doesn't go six
million dollars right it goes the 24 or
30 so when you short finding the things
to work on it can't be this linear if it
has to take this you know hockey-stick
people think about the hike stick I know
it sounds so easy it's not it is finding
data that shows hockey stick so as an
investor they first 30 days focus next
thing is it's starting to happen the
next 30 days it continues to happen so
that in those investor conversations
you're honest about it you're not like
you look at they did it but there's
something to talk about continuously and
it keeps going up in hey investor if you
give me money I can make this even go
faster that's to me kinda like the
90-day program it is about flow because
look as a founder and CEO there's so
many false positives in your data
there's so many negatives in taking the
time to kind of distill it down to three
things that move the needle that
fundamentally answer the question is
this a good idea is this working this is
going to be big it takes this like
exercise just pulling things apart and
ignoring the noise because what I've
always found is startups who do too many
things always know like you can be great
at one thing like until you have scale
against one thing don't do the second
and they're not idea like it's uber took
a long time before they do reads like a
long time right so that's after like
billions in the coffers most startups
before you raise 100 million you're
doing one thing for a very long time and
so a lot of this exercise is just saying
as the CEO you have 20 ideas and people
working on distill it down a little bit
and you'll find more velocity more truth
to your startup and then you when you go
talk to you the best fear it's much
easier to digest as well and I think
that we are glossing over one of those
important facts cuz you and I take it as
a obvious thing but it's really about
the experimentation right a lot of
people I think kind of early on and
especially the first or second company
that they go to build it's all about
like I know for a fact this is going to
work and investors if they're good at
anything like they see right through
that and what you're really describing
here is this idea of hey I'm running an
experiment that experiment is you give
me dollars here's what I think I can
accomplish I come back to you in you
know six twelve months and I say hey
those dollars you gave me I hit four of
the five things I thought I was gonna
hit give me more money here's the next
six that I'm gonna go ahead write it's
kind of this almost launched a bucket of
accomplishments and I think what you're
really saying is like you have to almost
understand what those possibilities are
and what you've actually been successful
doing in order to tell the story right
yeah nothing and I think it's it's it's
just it's good exercise really
understand what's happening I think I'm
always surprised when I talk to founders
about their company and ideas when I say
hey what about this data what if the
consumer walk me through the consumer
journey and tell me what's getting
better and why do you think that is and
we always say data data data it's just
not it's not about just showing graphs
right it's about articulating why like
why do you think that's happening and
can you can you replicate that over and
over and over and their defense ability
ultimately as the company everything can
be replicated there we close everywhere
but those that understand that why
always win right the why the secret
sauce is the thing people invest in
because ultimately whatever you are you
can be copied we've seen this happen and
every startup that's out there because
of the speed of the internet and Twitter
and CrunchBase and Cora and you name it
there's no like secret right that's too
hard to replicate this is just water in
a cannon the secret right
is what mike Caesarea the founder has in
his head and has how he creates the
culture and how he thinks about his fan
base and how he thinks the next thing
he's gonna do that emboldened and really
grows that passion those users that use
that voice and so you have to understand
the why and how to replicate it over and
over again and spend the time on the
data to see it and look at in different
perspectives and so yeah I there's every
startup you want to be either number one
or number two in the market there's
never a number three right and so being
number one usually you can get by being
first number two actually works to buy
fast follow but you also just have to
understand why so over lift examples etc
Dollar Shave Club in Perris was it was
the other example Don beachy rover they
actually end up merging there will
always be two in any market but one
typically pulls completely away from the
other
and typically it's because they
understand the customer what look air be
be home away was first then air B&B air
maybe I should understood the customer
better the younger demographic the
millennial you know whatever you want to
call it in the flexibility and they
pulled away so to me understanding the
insights in the human psychology of why
people talk about things why people
share on Instagram and Twitter and
Facebook in the tools that you give them
to a lot of times you look at big brands
they're fearful of somebody else taking
that brand and altering it remember the
days when like every brand be offended
if they saw like their logo on somebody
a user who just like took it and changed
it that you want your consumers to take
it and like make it their own version of
it right that's why supreme to god if
you got they thought like culture is
other people took something and like
made it different made it personal make
it made it individualism to some degree
today you have to allow that
you have to allow people to express
themselves and feel like they own part
of that idea
otherwise you'll fail so you know I
think what consumers enterprise is much
different I did enterprise for a very
long time that one's fascinating would I
enjoy consumer stuff what are the areas
in consumer that you're most excited
about right now or that you guys are
looking at saying hey somebody's gonna
go build a company in X vertical and if
you're working on it come talk to
science so we have a company it's
interesting we we announced the
fundraising right before the pendant and
let's go arrive outdoors and there's to
actually arrive outdoors
we've rent camping gear so the thesis
then was well you know everyone's recon
doing their lives and ones getting rid
of stuff but everybody wants experiences
and so we went premium like the highest
end camping gear but we ship it to you
nationwide pandemic hits everything
shuts down like but guess what the last
couple weeks what does everyone want to
do camping parks next we have the
exclusive with almost every state Park
National Park so you can go to arrive
outdoors right now
we'll send you clean plans their lives
like can't be equipment for you to use
when you're done shove it in box send it
back to us
we'll clean and sterilize for the next
customer that like so what is that
that's behavior part so what does the
world look like six to twelve months
from now when we start a battle and we
thought well nobody has storage nobody
has garages and everyone wants to do the
experiences they want deal with
different people they went do different
places so if I camp where it's hot
versus where it rain for four people
were eight people it's like different
gear you're not gonna collect all the
stuff but you also want the nice stuff
the stuff that's you know like the
high-end things that aren't gonna break
down behind things that are the nicest
materials that keep you warm and now
it's just interesting we got timings
everything right like we also are
hitting this time where everyone must be
outdoors
that's the types of behaviors lambs is
another one
it's interesting like I think
universally most people would not
want to hold their phone against their
head all day right
now whether you believe it actually
causes cancer or not it's less about
that it's that maybe we don't know
enough they may just turn out that just
like tobacco was supposed to be okay
with the for us and sugar was okay for
us and and you know Teflon was okay for
us maybe like cellphones and Wi-Fi I'm
not a conspiracy theorist at all but
maybe so why wouldn't you protect
yourself so lambs right you can buy we
and proof underwear hats
beanies we have this thing called the
snapback blows it's a Silver Line glove
that you can slide in your hand to open
up doors you don't touch it but the
brand is really about like protective
clothing that you know it's nice it
works it's comfortable why wouldn't you
wear this underwear if you're trying to
get pregnant or you actually think you
know maybe it does cause cancer so so
the new stuff you know we're launching
is cereal if I'm still say that yet but
we're launching a cereal brand I think
about launching brands that are
unexpected this one's amazing and she's
one of those people you know I think
creativity when we think about brands a
lot of it will be the founder the
creativity and something that is worth
talking about when I think about
experiences that are utilizing what's
changed so we're thinking about how to
not just regular homeschooling so for
everybody who's got kids on zoom' what's
the product that they might be liking
that means we're incubating something
around that we're doing music I mean we
have a reputable and we're hip-hop and
trot music so you know there's to me
entertainment is still a big part of
what we think about wanting to do and
wishbone and yarn or to top 200 apps in
the App Store right that's us and that's
just people want to be entertained short
form stories people want its quizzes
you'll see this big announcement we're
doing in a couple days with one of the
platforms
you know ultimately we get lots of
inbound the ideas we want to see our if
it's a brand what's different like tell
me why are people going to talk about it
right if it's experiential services like
an arrive outdoors or dog bake Kailas
where fundaments is a different way to
do something through a service why and
how does it scale and in third auntie me
if it's an app or if it's my eSports
play versus a pre calm like that to me
is a something to do on your mobile
device that's not Instagram that's not
Facebook that's not snapchat so what is
that thing you know right now it's we
have a wishbone yarn pray calm flavors
of the suits it's a lot of these ideas
for us are
I know when I see it my partners know
what let me see it and it's a lot of gut
you know parent like do we believe you
know real blocks is a company that when
I saw I said do we believe DocuSign is
the last thing we'll ever see in
digitization of an asset like that's a
crazy right so we all I'm sure we all
understand the value of creating digital
assets and real blocks is looking at
taking real world big bank assets REITs
securities and then taking that whole
automation of back-end of it is the the
idea of putting that in digital form and
making it globally accessible it's gonna
happen whether it's today tomorrow
there's no doubts there is an irrational
personal world that would say like at
some point isn't it crazy that if you
love the Tesla stock if I'm in the in
some country like name it like I'm in
Vietnam like how do i buy tesla spot on
the Nasdaq like I can't do that unless
I'm loved
I'm gonna count with Chase Citibank I
think you know that's not the way the
world is going to work and so
globalization of assets as you know you
know science was one of the few reg D
tokens that was ever created and to us
that was a little tremendous learning of
how hard it is right to do and so you
know we're we're still working on a
bunch of crazy ideas right we have
protego launching soon which is a
custody in a trust company and we're one
of the only things that exist in the
world that you can take any assets and
put it in custody it could be your house
it could be big going to be kind of any
assets I like thinking the world in that
manner where
what's it gonna be in a year to tears
I'm not a five-year person in ten knots
telling the future to me twelve to
eighteen months is not about like I'm
smart its observing the relevant
information at hands a day like arrive
is like well people want to camp people
don't want to own things like that so to
tell you that store that in a year we're
in a rental on Academy here wasn't a
stretch you know plastic bottles people
should don't drink ban plastic straws to
think that water and it can might take
money it isn't too big of a stretch
and so I'm much more the that that's
been my skill as an investor twelve to
eighteen months maybe two years ten
years we can have opinions on not online
in one week that longs to know if I'm
right that's my skill and I don't want
to have fun and want to love the founder
I want to I want that founder to have a
relationship with me that's just a lot
different and much truer but I'm all
like like this doesn't work for me that
right like I know you don't work like
it's not work when you love what you do
and it's like we wake up to do these
things that's what I did my my one thing
that I think I've learned from you is
you were talking earlier about kind of
telling the story and I think one thing
that people don't realize that you do
probably better than anyone I've ever
seen is you practice I've heard you
literally pitch liquid death probably
500 times while I'm with you too as
you're handing the can and it was all
before that the big last fundraise right
and so like all of that repetition every
time was it exactly the same but it went
from hey there's his water in this can
that you know was kind of what I would
assume most people would start at two by
the time the 500th time I heard you say
it I was like damn that's pretty
compelling like there's not that many
people who are gonna say no to that the
funny thing is you see practice but I
it's like I don't my whole life I've
never and when I do talks I don't write
him down it's always off-the-cuff John
Oates but I don't because I it's mostly
because I have a really bad memory like
diagnosed with ADHD bottom 16%
it's just the pitch I just means based
on people's reaction right and I just
adjust adjust it so when I say 7000 nose
though 7000 nose got to a couple hundred
yeses just because every time I'm just
watching and we actually I'm listening
to reaction what do they have questions
about how can I essentially in advance
answer the question in a [ __ ] so part
of pitching is repetition you can call
it practice but talking it out loud to
people normal people like gen-pop who
aren't investors do they understand what
you're telling then through the lens and
investor every time you get the question
like I don't know why this why this why
this if you can weave in your narrative
that answer before you think you know
the question is gonna come what you want
is a dialogue where you do pitch for
five minutes and the rest is just like
conversation not questions because
you've answered all these things like
why now why this you know why now why
would this work I don't understand if
you tell you pitch in a way by kind of
answering those questions along you
don't waste that 30 minutes you have
with an investor I always think even
though people say it it's an hour you
really have my opinion you have about 15
minutes like you know maybe less you've
got to capture them inside the first few
minutes 15 minutes a meeting that goes
longer than one hour you have them the
last thing I'll say is there's a 24 hour
rule I have if an investor doesn't call
you text you message you he'll even like
a tweet of yours within 24 hours
it's an isn't no move on fast nose is
all I've ever asked for my investors
like it's now I'm not offended if you
pass like it's if it's not your things
not your thing what's the worst is slow
nose because you're just it's like hope
to an entrepreneur you're giving them
hope in that sucks like just cut it so
they can move on like they need to move
on they need to move on and so if you're
an entrepreneur out there
you're pitching people if they if they
haven't gotten that to you don't like
don't waste energy hoping right and
you're not a teacher you are not as an
entrepreneur built to educate everybody
so just because an ambassador asked the
question does not mean you have to
answer it is not truth serum like it is
amazing when I found her like I told him
this like why would you tell them
everything like they're they're not on
the board they're not an investment
that's information only for us and so
remember the power dynamics is that I
don't say I never think say things like
we're raising money I don't like to say
that right and when I talk to better I'm
talking about we're looking for people
who can be a part of this right would
you like to privileged to invest like
make it feel like it's a privilege like
they have to sell you a little bit and
it's a really mental thing into the back
pan if anybody out there who's raised
money before the moment you get somebody
you get a term sheet all of a sudden you
are so much more confident to the next
investment nothing actually changed
right except your confidence into that
next pitch and all sudden like the
momentum of the clothes happens if
you've ever raised money take that
feeling and try to pitch like that all
the time
pitch with confidence not arrogance
there's a big difference don't pitch
with arrogance I hate that pitch with
confidence that you're looking for
somebody to be a part of this that it is
a it should be rightfully so if you're
building a company that's going to be
worth more money they are lucky to be
investing right this it's this
relationship where you're saying look if
you give us dollars I'm in return giving
making more money but don't death the
desperation thing never works it's a
really interesting dynamic in a
psychology thing when raising money that
your shares and equity the company is
very very valuable treat it like so
because if you treat it like it's not
why would investor want to give you
money if you don't anything that's
valuable
so it
subtlety's it's a lot of
subconsciousness around that every great
entrepreneur knows that the investor
needs them in order to to make a return
on the fund where um where can people
find you on the internet and find out
more about science if they want to get
in touch with you guys I'm a Twitter guy
at Peter Pham my Twitter is really it is
if you follow me it is there's no agenda
it is it's diarrhea it just falls out
like it's just
you should strike that word it basically
is my emotion I wear it on my sleeve
it's Noble it's no BS I you know I
definitely my PR firm tells me I
shouldn't be tweeting so much about
things but Twitter its it's my true self
i I really don't look for validation I
am Who I am I've confidence in what I'm
doing so Twitter is the best hit me up
my demons are open I read everything if
I don't reply you know sometimes it does
get buried email as well but science
dang calm info app we read everything
all the partners open up there be email
so we do reply and I would say as we
look through the trying times right now
I will say we are proud we're very
diverse in investments you know we have
a lot of women we have a lot of black
founders and I think that's a subset of
being in LA more than anything else like
that's just what we grew up with we
don't have Stanford grads down here
suppose we say that and it just has to
resonate we don't ever take offense to
investors that know you know that's a no
it's just not it's just timing
serendipity is so much of this how many
investments have you done where it was
San dippity meeting most of them I don't
know the exact percentage but definitely
most of them in the sense of and some of
it too is if you look back some of it is
you know people who are doing the deal
and they think of you because of
something that
did or said in the past and they just
say hey I knew you're interested in this
some of it is founders who say like I
specifically want you to come do this
and here's how you can be helpful and
then some of it is like going and
looking for things right so there's no
like one single bucket but most of it if
you look back you kind of laugh at like
how it came together but hey it works I
know the other day not every stocks
gonna work out like we have to just be
real and I've had my failures
everybody's had their failures it is the
numbers game and I always start back
from zero like it's who cares what you
did in the past like the now right and
so I always have this mentality like I
have to work hard I gotta try I gotta
make the effort and put it in and I
think as an investor things that burned
you in the past
don't let it really really hinder your
investments in the future like that was
that's a big big lesson it's kind of
like if you today mister we're talking
most of the stock market how many stocks
right now if you look at it you owned
way early then you sold and then it went
up and you know it's too expensive and
now it's twice as much now are three
times like I bought my Tesla 200 and
something sold at seven something big
here so it's gonna hit a thousand ah I
might still buy more because I am
actually long Tesla or whatever the
stock is like Amazon is the stock I'll
buy forever and so there's if you look
at investments one of the biggest
lessons right now even as early is if
you love the company in the 80 and the
founder and it got too expensive last
time you know if your thesis is a fun
will allow it you should still probably
mess or at least personally invest
because great companies they great so
yeah this is [ __ ] like the ultimate
fundraiser I love it
right so you can still call me and we're
raising money for a lot of things but
we're actually you know we're raising
our next fund right now and it's it's
like to me I I love that we are allowed
to do this it's it's a privilege are you
kidding me but they how lucky are we
it's I yet I am never ever ever
forgetful and how lucky I am to do this
job like so we gotta pay attention you
got to do you got to put the work lp's
give me money
expecting returns I better be I'm gonna
be hustling so but it's it's fun you're
an absolute legend I appreciate you
doing this I couldn't speak more highly
of you guys over at science so any
founders who are listening to this
please please please go reach out to
them because they got their receipts me
they know how to build companies I'll
just wait oh that's a big that's what
kills me
you know you ever sit there and think
you know I the fast forward we're gonna
the fast four part I can't wait till
next year like the things that are
happening that you know and and that's
the I think I'm inside for me having the
studio part and the fund is like we have
different perspective I have a different
lens on all my investments right as a
fund investor what I'm investing into
liquid as well I know more than any
investor we were they started in offices
right and so it's when you and you it's
too hard to articulate cuz it's just too
much information that to me is
everything like we all human beings just
want to be right right like at our core
we just want to be right and that's it
I'm insight I I know and I can admit
that so people are saying my bias is
like you're only posting data that fit
your narrative of course I am like
that's what like that's what everybody
that's what that's human nature right so
yeah just just I'm so excited for some
of these companies right now that
hopefully it'll work right glass is
always half full from that's never like
to live in that other side I don't
understand I just so sad it's so sad I
couldn't agree more
we we are gonna have to do this again
for sure when when this stuff comes to
fruition because I think that uh the
things you guys are working on are
always awesome but because I've
definitely done a fantastic job kind of
navigating all the recent chaos so thank
you again for taking the time to do this
Thanks you're so you know this Joe Rogan
is a hundred million what are you gonna
go for come on
but please Joe uh Joe has a 14 year head
start on everybody else that's what
people forget is he for comment no
comment